[Música]
si cuando es grave el paciente debe
pasar a la terapia intensiva buscan
espacios la terapia intensiva aquí en
hospital tenemos ocho camas que siempre
están llenas y no tenemos donde colocar
y otro problema es que la falta personal
no existe suficientemente personal
tenemos
enfermeras y médicos enfermos con dengue
de baja y no tengo con quién reemplazar
la terapia intensiva
[Música]
el yo yo normal ese día que mi hijo se
puso mal el día miércoles en la noche yo
a las 2 de la mañana corría al hospital
a donde mi zona donde vivo en la primera
en la villa y hartos niños y llegaban y
llegaban cada rato de esa hora yo vi que
ganar niños con sus madres y sus padres
así con los mismos síntomas que tenía mi
[Música]